le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
avant de pouvoir travailler il faut
apprendre pendant toute sa scolarité
on apprend à lire à écrire à l'étudier
et à se concentrer
l'apprentissage est indispensable et
contribuer activement à la réussite
professionnelle mais une réussite
scolaire n'aboutit pas systématiquement
à une embauche car le manque
d'expérience freine les employeurs alors
comment acquérir de l'expérience
professionnelle tout en faisant ses
études
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
virginie a 21 ans et c'est d'un pas
motivée qu'elle se rend à son travail
depuis quelques mois maintenant son
application et sa détermination font de
cette jeune femme une employée modèle
pourtant virginie n'est pas embauché
définitivement mais fait un contrat
d'apprentissage dans le cadre de son
année d'études
cette année virginie prépare un master
en ressources humaines et organisation
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
un tel niveau d'étude n'est pas
forcément associée à une embauche facile
les employeurs refusent parfois des
embauches avec un prétexte assez
contradictoires sur diplômés mais cette
raison n'est pas la seule car pour
augmenter ses chances d'obtenir un
emploi quel que soit le niveau d'études
mieux vaut avoir de l'expérience
professionnelle
le contrat d'apprentissage est donc un
dispositif très intéressant car il
permet de finir ses études avec de
l'expérience professionnelle
virginie est bien consciente de la
valeur de ce contrat
alors le contrat d'apprentissage est
pour moi un levier d'insertion
professionnelle c'est également un
ticket donc pour l'accès à une formation
professionnalisant donc qui permet
d'élargir nos connaissances et surtout
d'acquérir de nouvelles compétences sur
le lieu de travail
j'ai décidé de faire mon contrat
d'apprentissage au sein du conseil
général car j'ai déjà effectué un stage
en début d'année dans le cadre de ma
licence en gestion des entreprises qui
s'est très bien passé aussi il faut
rajouter que c'est ici sur l'île donc ça
me permet de rester près de ma famille
de mes proches c'est également une
grosse collectivité qui gère plus de
5000 agents donc dans le domaine des
ressources humaines c'est très
enrichissant
en termes de connaissances sur les deux
compétences à acquérir donc à terme
après la réussite de mon diplôme dont
j'aimerais intégrer une entreprise
publique ou privée sur la dépense mais
j'aimerais rester dans le domaine des
ressources humaines afin de pouvoir
m'épanouir professionnellement
aussi j'aimerais rester sur lies
pourquoi tout simplement parce que j'ai
des projets professionnels et cela le
cas mais très d'allier vie privée vie
professionnelle tout en gardant le
sourire comme dire giny beaucoup de
jeunes réunionnais veulent réussir et
s'épanouir professionnellement un
objectif ordinaire mais compliqué à
notre époque à cause des difficultés que
rencontrent les entreprises
qu'elles soient privées ou publiques les
entreprises s'efforcent de participer à
cette démarche en intégrant des contrats
d'apprentissage au sein de leur équipe
le département est très impliqué dans ce
domaine chaque année beaucoup de
contrats d'apprentissage sont signés au
conseil général
une démarche solidaire visant à soutenir
et à aider la jeunesse réunionnaise
le contrat d'apprentissage est partie de
la politique volontariste du conseil
général en attire du public jeune pour
autant il ya aussi d'autres dispositifs
tels que le pack jeune la mobilité avec
le tarn la volonté du conseil général de
financer plus de 750 emplois d'avenir
dont 250 en direct le parcours de
l'insertion professionnelle que ce soit
au niveau de la formation que ce soit en
termes de contrats aidés
donc ça démontre bien que la volonté du
conseil général en tout cas d'aidé ce
public jeune le contrat d'apprentissage
est une expérience formidable pour nos
jeunes puisque tant au niveau théorique
et pratique il y as obou cette
expérience qui permettra justement à nos
jeunes plus tard et bien d'avoir une
expérience très fortes dans son parcours
professionnel
ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que nous
avons quand même un taux de réussite de
plus de 66%
donc ce qui conforte notre choix
d'accentuer en tout cas ce dispositif
puisque depuis 2006 jusqu'aujourd'hui
plus de 500 contrats d'apprentissage ont
été signés et pour la seule année 2013
plus de 100 contrats étaient signés donc
ça démontre bien la volonté du conseil
général en tout cas de s'inscrire dans
dans cette démarche
ce sont les étudiants d'aujourd'hui qui
feront la réunion de demain
le conseil général tient à ce que notre
département continue de soutenir nos
cadets et fait le nécessaire pour que la
jeunesse réunionnaise est une bonne
situation professionnelle car c'est un
facteur indispensable au bon équilibre
des foyers et des familles dont ils
seront les acteurs le conseil général de
la réunion vous a présenté lien social
le conseil général aux côtés des
réunionnais